you
oh there's only 19 minutes left I'm
still gonna try it I'm jumping in copy
if you want to jump in this one real
quick this is the one I'm playing in
starting seven minutes late
top guy has 9 no I can't move fast
I can't move as fast as I would like
okay let's let's pile up on that pinned
pawn
let's be persistent okay I'm gonna win
that and then hang on to the pond now
forget about the pond we want to get
here I'm gonna get out of the pin my
queen wants to be cemented ooh it's
going to say my queen wants to be
cemented on d5 they just out of nowhere
drop their queen maybe they meant queen
f4 probably okay I got two pretty quick
win new game plus we're gonna see about
establishing pawns on e5 and look for
some attack against the King maybe as
both white and black okay and the next
phase is to have the bishop point at h7
which is a square that a knight cannot
control anymore because of this guy he's
immune from capture let's over protect
d4 still protect my knight and maybe we
dropped the bishop back let's see what
side they're gonna go I could take the
beep on but their queen would close to
know they're close to being trapped no
and we could still look to attack the
King now let's kick that night away
and secure my night for the moment and
we're gonna move forward I'm hitting
their night might miss that mmm I like
my bishops too much
let's hit the night didn't take here
yeah why not
hmm my queen should do something better
than sit on b4 I wanted to get here 19
seconds all right she's getting active
at least
okay well they officially got the Queen
trade in there now all I have is time
burners back to tournament ugly all
right I'm still I'm at four I was gonna
say I'm still on page two I'm on page
three top is at 17 now okay I'm in 28th
there are a hundred and eight players in
here okay this guy again haven't played
him uh oops in this tournament but we've
played few times now winning upon moving
very fast okay I have that square
covered take that pond yeah ship here
looking for some
or nation 94 let's see about a queen
trade hmm
let's get a flight square in there let's
go here I want to trade the bishop for
their night I get my Bishop on a safe
square and how about I'm okay with this
the rooks out of place um no I think I
have that they saw that one coming
even being up a pawn is not going to be
enough I don't think no we're back to
even on time just want to take that
night that takes night it should be
easier to play here hmm all right it's
made if they take oh this is going to be
me this is a
King and pawn ending oh they're down on
time whoo okay we are now I think in
paid yeah number 10 I keep forgetting
that the thing registers right here okay
so I'm going to gain the tempo against
the Queen I thought they were going to
recapture okay they don't they're not
playing with their see pawns so there's
not I have some good security over d4
and no we running like this
think about getting in a c5 break see if
they strengthen my structure
oh just push she could be hunted down
quite easily
you know this and then in the end these
two pawns are weaknesses I need a flight
square still I guess this is the one
we're gonna go with and maybe we could
get this guy got him let's give a check
and let's defend here g4 king g3 sneak
my king over I'm not sure what that one
was doing probably should have started
pushing my pawns sooner let's start with
this like what's war about right now not
right now okay what are you doing a
mouse slipping flush that King back man
be a king Fletcher
well said man well said less than five
they're in the think tank I love it here
we go
and they have two seconds don't try to
win this objectively just burn their
time okay
they're down to my goodness
still 12 minutes left I'm in ninth with
13 so much for my idea didn't I say I'm
gonna try to establish pawns on e5
whatever happened to that you got away
from what you said you're gonna do I
already know what's their King gonna do
where's he going I got a pressure here
and this know they could just block with
the Queen no that's not working now I
get this yeah I'll take care pretty uh
it's pretty serious now take again I
just take every Bishop on why don't you
oh okay I could get out of stuff with
this check and then here next is going
to win a piece and I was going to take
the rook they resign okay we got 16 top
is 30 I'm paired up with who is probably
my most frequent opponent Hovick
got over 60 games in man all right
prepared to meet Queen b3 with Queen b6
I have time to take and then get off of
this yes I do
let's go here and then here hmm okay
that Bishop position is a little
annoying okay now I could do this stuff
no I'd take are you running it like that
now my rook could defend laterally at
least on the dark squares I have this
square covered what's my knight super
defender here all right it's over
protect it um yeah I think he needs to
reposition my Knights need to do
something else that seemed to help me
that one too so I'm slowly making some
progress
what's their knight up to hmm I could do
this I want to keep one rook on the
board 14 seconds
this game isn't finishing
mm-hmm okay I could get these next moves
in fast nope they're down in time oh man
okay I'm at 20 the top guy mmm the top
the top three that are ahead of me don't
have fire I'm back ten though ten is a
lot 130 are in this one less than nine
here's the number one guy so here's my
chance to at least catch up some against
this guy
man you could do it giving up the bishop
okay let's challenge the piece that's in
my position all right gonna undermine
that Knight position looking for c5 c5
soon Oh guess we'll take care taking
what the Queen Jeep on I have a strong
bishop he's maybe a bad Bishop but I'm
on f2 directly the Queen has to drop
back then I have very active Queen post
take the a pawn rook a one is super
passive there Knight isn't playing
let's take upon can maybe take g3 at
some stage yeah the rook isn't playing
let's give this check stay on this
diagonal actually they could force a
queen trade now you get active with the
rook chase him away and the rook is tied
down there Knight is very restricted and
soon we have this keep pressure on upon
let's take the rook I guess and let's
just get some air for my king
there's no tricky Perpetua with the
knight is there not they moved I didn't
see it threatening mate eight seconds
and here they're down
I'm back to Turman whoo okay well I
caught up against the number-one guy I
wasn't fourth now in sixth and I'm
paired up against Benko man okay hmm
let's secure my bishop on d6 if allowed
they got that in there fast let's try it
now play so it's my queen rook to e8
yeah I'm in a tough spot
I want my king on d6 now they're really
soon this ending I don't know is it
ending or more like a middle game okay
get rid of the night my king is still
fine where he's at I believe you get one
trade of the rooks that's it okay he
might be a liability get active with the
rook very active now we're gonna think
about g5 soon give a check and then go
here I need to undermine their structure
they have a connected past pond yeah but
check maybe I shouldn't have done that
they're not moving there clock's ticking
is there an issue with the site or did
they have a connection issue what's the
story I made my move I made my move
don't tell me my clock is really ticking
they're down on time
yeah who
something happened there with their
connection mmm okay I have 28 I'm four
back from the leader four minutes left
all right be 45 all right maybe we just
looked to get an e for somehow yeah
let's let's run it like this keep some
pieces on anchor my bishop in with H for
mm-hmm I think they could play Knight
takes pawn here let's try for some
tricks gonna give me that mm-hmm maybe I
just go for a sacrifice of h6 maybe
Bishop here lien here
fishing here RNA one move threats that
are easily prevented at some point they
could just take my bishop like right now
but I'm back here oh and there goes the
Queen okay time to stare at the clock
and hope for the best
grab a phone keep pieces on don't keep
it simple I'll get one trade in there I
still have a knight he's worth a lot
plenty of time burning ideas in mind
with the night they were gonna go here
ah they were they did and they're gonna
get made it really soon prove the king
no stalemates they're down on time back
determine woo he drew and oh this is a
big one
cuz I have fire even if I didn't will
there be time to get this one in I'm
gonna go for a queen trade ah
there's always known affright tricks
this is an excellent structure for black
not sure what they're doing at rook b1
oh and just go fast man let's go with
this rook 94 but I wanted let's get rid
of their nighttime on the rook my other
night on d6 would be excellent
keep pressure here yeah I definitely
have to cover this square knight on f5
I'm threatening everything I got this
take that pond 47 seconds my king where
do you want to be men they moved I
didn't see it 33 seconds I don't think
we're gonna get this one in not good
nine seconds their downtime just in time
just in time I got that one in
I got it in Oh a buzzer-beater oh man
36 34 I was just staring at the clock
towards the end I'm like I'm trying to
win this objectively and then I had to
switch gears oh man
36 34 34 oh I'll take it
man that was really really close it
doesn't get any closer than oh my
goodness I just kept looking it was
tough it was really tough I was looking
at the I was looking at the board and
then I'm like I have to look at the
clock time of my opponent and then the
game time oh man
36 34 34 32 oh my goodness
there's page one got 14 pages here
let's see what's who took part in this
one go a lot of pages this was an arena
all right Wow - the 137 of you took part
in this good games uh-huh
man a buzzer-beater
and big time
you